20 ans jean marc morandini
bonsoir jean marc alors jean marc tout
le monde parle de votre émission
consacrée à la télévision sur europe 1
et à 38 ans vous effectué un come back
réussi comme journaliste et comme
rédacteur en chef
ça prouve et finalement que que l'on
peut sortir des petites cases dans
lesquelles on vous mais d'une certaine
façon heureusement heureusement je
croyais que c'était impossible en france
pensait qu'on était à vie dans ces
petites cases animateur de télé trash
etc
je m'aperçois qu'on peut en sortir c'est
pas mal voilà il ya il ya quand même une
ya une vie après la télé ben oui la
preuve
voilà alors votre émission c'est tous
les jours de 10h30 à 12h sur europe 1
vous êtes le leader des émissions de
radio consacrée à la télévision alors
pendant longtemps il faut dire les
choses les radios n'ont pas voulu parler
de la télévision de lendemain parce que
ça voulait dire que si on parlait il
s'était passé et qu'elle ne l'écouté pas
la radio bon et puis un jour ils sont ni
dans le fond de son personnes écoutent
la radio le soir c'est clair pas grand
monde dix ans donc on va parler de la
télé vous avez été le premier sur rmc
info
et ça a pris une importance considérable
puisqu'il ya vous il ya evelyne thomas
le salary ghost writer voilà et marco
biagi m6 etc
alors donc c'est chez vous jean marc
morandini sur rmc que bernard montiel a
fait sans hara kiri médiatique en direct
vous l'aviez averti vous pendant la pub
pendant la q2 j'ai dit fais attention tu
balances vraiment beaucoup et lui m'a
dit écoute façon c'est pas grave j'ai
pas d'amis dans ce métier donc ça
passera avec personne à la mairie bien
moi je trouve ça plutôt courageux c'est
bien à lombez bien alors montiel a été
viré de tf1 comme vous mais pas pour les
mêmes raisons finalement vous donc
l'émission à l'époque c'était tout est
possible l'émission qui faisait 65% de
parts de marché du délire quand on y
repense aujourd'hui c'est incroyable ce
trailer parce qu'aujourd'hui quand une
certaine émission francs 45 % mais 65%
de parts de marché ça c'est évidemment
voilà mais s'il est dans le titre
et tout est possible et la direction de
tf1 voulu
vous continuiez à oui tout à fait la
démission ont duré quatre ans au bout de
la troisième année moi j'ai voulu
arrêter parce que l'émission ne
correspondait plus vraiment moi j'ai dit
je veux arrêter était façon en la
mâtinant il faut continuer c'est une
émission qui cartonne donc j'ai continué
à une année plus à la fin vraiment j'en
pouvais plus quasthoff mais alors qu'ils
avaient été virés en fait pas par tf1
mais par la presse oui on peut dire ça
comme ça c'est vrai qu'à une vraie
campagne de presse contre l'émission qui
trouvait les missions beaucoup trop
trash et c'est d'ailleurs assez drôle
quand on voit les programmes
d'aujourd'hui parce que quand on fait
aujourd'hui à la télé on se rend compte
que c'était cette émission pour les
enfants de choeur ok tout est possible
non mais c'est vrai que ça vachement
comment est-ce que tu peux réagir par
rapport aux gens qui t'appelle puisque
toi qui à la base de cette télé trash
fait je connais les mécaniques de ces
émissions est en fait le message que
j'essaie de faire passer aux gens sur
europe 1 c'est de leur dire ne vous
laissez pas avoir par ce type d'émission
voilà comment ça se passe derrière voilà
quels sont les coulisses de ce type
d'émissions
ouais libération avec un petit tri
demeurant dit un con et je trouve que
c'est très violent d'attaquer les gens
dont ce qu'ils sont dire ce mec là est
un con juste parce qu'on l'a vu une
heure et demie par mois à la télé ça n'a
pas de sens mais pourquoi aujourd'hui la
presse dit pas fontaine et batailles
sont des camps où tout ça pourquoi ça a
changé ça je sais pas je sais pas
pourquoi ça a changé mais je pense que
c'est vrai qu'on ya tellement des
missions de ce type là aujourd'hui que
c'est un peu noyés dans la masse enfin
beaucoup et qui est interdit dans la
presse française bien non alors vous
avez été accusé jean marc morandini de
voyeurisme de racolage évidemment vous
sentiez un petit peu quand vous faisiez
l'émission parce que bon vous êtes
conscient de ce que vous faites vous
avez tenté de déprogrammer un reportage
où une jeune femme s'était inoculé le
sida
par amour pour son compagnon qui était
atteint de la maladie c'est vrai que ça
fait partie des choses vraiment là je
trouvais que la limite était dépassé
mais problème c'est que dans cette
émission tout est possible moi je
n'avais pas la main sur l'émission
c'était pas le producteur de lait mise
en fait j'étais simplement le
présentateur est donc bien j'arrive et
on me disait voilà le sommaire c'est ça
il ya tel sujet tel sujet moi j'étais en
plateau et je présentais l'émission donc
vraiment quand ça allait trop loin comme
dans ce cas précis j'arrivais à mettre
un holà mais il fallait vraiment se
battre
il ya un autre cas aussi vous avez
interrompu ses l'entretien avec un homme
qui avait vendu ses deux enfants pour
cent mille francs même vous vous aviez
avantage sur la famille qui avait acheté
les enfants étaient très mécontents
quand j'ai reçu ce mec là je pensais que
je pensais qu'ils auraient exprimé des
remords il n'avait aucun remords c'est
un truc que je comprends pas excusez moi
mais c'est quand la presse et savent
bien qui décide des sujets non dans la
presse ne s'est pas la presse ne sait
pas qui est à la traîne cette émission
la presse vous accusez vous alors que la
vraie responsable c'est pascale breugnot
mais pascale breugnot elle a une image
aujourd'hui d'une fille formidable qui a
fait psy show qui a fait avancer la télé
reste lancement milliards d'animaux non
mais c'est vrai pascale breugnot
aujourd'hui celle en haut des tours
c'était moins l'image de l'émission donc
c'est vrai qu'il fallait pas tout mettre
dessus mais c'est aussi normal
franchement je fasse partie des gens qui
est accusé un moment moi je m'en veux
pour certaines choses je m'en veux de ne
pas avoir dit non plus vraiment non plus
c'est vrai que moi en tant que
présentateur un moment j'aurais pu dire
non je deviens plus je ne présente plus
cette émission ça c'est une des erreurs
les fêtes ça me laisser emporter les
temps quand un crime une mercedes
exactement c'est clair en même temps
j'avais 25 ans j'étais sur tf1 en
deuxième partie de soirée c'était la
première fois de ma vie qui présentait
une émission on est un peu ébahi par
tout ça à l'époque
à l'époque jean marc était assez stressé
à l'époque donneuse ap pas il était
assez stressé vous avez perdu 13 super
13 kg près c'est vrai qu'à l'époque un
petit peu comme comme neutres michèle
laroque vous pensiez vous exiler
non c'est vrai j'avais envie de partir
parce que je pensais sincèrement qu'en
france avec l'image qui avait véhiculé
la presse plus personne dans les médias
ne me ferais confié enfin chance et que
cette image vraiment difficile que
j'avais allait ruiner à tout jamais mais
ma carrière en france assouplit je vais
partir aux etats-unis la banque connaît
pas et je vais faire à nouveau mes
préférés ya un truc moi j'ai connu ça
c'est d'ailleurs quand on a perdu son
job à la télé même si on s'en fout un
peu parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi
un moment bon ça soulage un peu pour
dire la vérité mais on ne peut pas
échapper aux chauffeurs de taxi qui vous
disent avaient dit non à lyon je
comprends pas pourquoi ils vous ont bien
et parce que vous étiez pas mal sûr
alors ce qu'ils ont mis à la place là
franchement c'est pas mieux et donc
c'était lille parce qu'en fait il
faudrait vraiment sexy ou si oui on y
pense plus dense pour nous les
chauffeurs de taxi qui disons pour vous
vous aviez annoncé à l'époque à la
télévision à la célébrité et puis vous
êtes allé sur chérie fm sur nostalgie
j'ai fait doubler l'audience s'était il
faut savoir quand même que jean marc
morandini tamek qui fait doubler
l'audience
tu vas voir demain ça va doubler
l'audience correctionnelle savard sais
que c'est pas la peine que je monte mon
curriculum remarquer c'est toujours
je crois savoir que ton cul ne rentre
pas dans l'écran cash et moi mon cou et
jarrod
c'est ça alors parallèlement à l'époque
vous avez été intéressé par internet
vous avez créé tout est net et
génération gay point fr est-ce que
c'était parce que c'est important de
défendre la cause gay ou pour vous faire
plein de pognon fortement parce que
c'était un vrai créneau porteur à ce
moment c'est à paris n'a pas été ménagé
avec sa demande par la nasa pas voir ça
en revanche comme ça a recommencé à
marcher effectivement c'est sur rmc donc
alan ces infos émission sur la télé
bonne idée on l'a dit et vous augmentez
relationnel padula doubler l'audience il
l'a augmentée de 135% attentats patata
moi j'ai travaillé rmc sont des copains
est tous là bas
135% c'était facile suffisait qu'ils et
deux t2 auditeurs de plus depuis des
mois les copains peux pas m'empêcher fin
je les aime
alors le problème est immense vous êtes
tombés sur des sur des patrons un petit
peu c'est normal pour des patrons un
petit peu âpres au gain ce qu'ils
voulaient aussi des coups de téléphone
des auditeurs nombreux et ayant alors
maintenant jean marc morandini tout le
monde attend votre retour à la
télévision
on parle de france 3 le vendredi soir
une deuxième partie de soirée quand
notre ami marc olivier fogiel sera enfin
le dimanche soir oui c'est un projet
part d'un projet parmi d'odeur produit
par dechavanne produit par le chas 26
celui-là beauty se serait produit par de
ces deux projets oui à deux projets
c'est vrai que depuis que l'on parle un
peu de moi à nouveau et que c'est vrai
que ça marche c'est vrai que de suivre
sa marche bien sur europe 1 et pas mal
de producteurs qui viennent me voir qui
me propose des émissions mais c'est vrai
que je veux pas refaire les erreurs du
passé
dire que moi j'ai une condition qui est
importante c'est de dire je veux être le
patron de mon émission et voilà j'ai
payé une fois pour voir donc ça suffit
j'ai appris aujourd'hui c'est fait une
émission je vais être le patron mon
émission et surtout je veux rester libre
de pouvoir dire ce que je veux en radio
sur europe 1 parce que c'est vrai que
l'une des particularités de l'émission
c'est la liberté de ton et je veux
garder cette liberté de pouvoir
critiquer toutes les chaînes alors ça
vous plairait de revenir dans la grande
famille de la télévision jean marc
encore une fois voilà mes conditions ici
sont mes conditions oui vous savez quand
on fait partie de la grande famille la
télévision on est obligé d'aller faire
des courses de voitures avec dechavanne
le dimanche vous savez ça tu vas être
obligé de marcher sur les genoux parce
que tu n'as pas le droit d'être plus
grands
c'est la série
cela vous dérange pas d'être obligé de
les faire du dragster avec vincent
perrot oui quand on fait partie de la
grande famille de la télévision offert
la course du rhum avec christine bravo
vous savez ça oui ce sera plus simple
en tous les cas vous pensez avoir la
télévision la même liberté que vous avez
aujourd'hui à la radio non je ne sais
pas en tout cas c'est la condition pour
y aller si j'ai pas cette liberté j'irai
parenté suis pas un accro de la télé et
je ne pense pas que la radio toute façon
soit quelque chose de mineur
aujourd'hui c'est vrai quand on fait de
la radio la première question qu'on vous
pose c mais vous revenez quand on avait
moi je suis très bien radio qui fait de
la télé bien c'est bien autre membre a
raté j bonne salle des fêtes vous
désirez gens